[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les qualités incroyables c'est parce que
je t'ai les rentes avs deux ans regarde
là oui je sens plus mais moi ça c'était
surtout les attends je te rend si ton
micro
merci ils marchent pas les buzzer oui il
marche il marche dans les pas du tout
merci mon besoin d'amour ça va c'est gai
on est un dialecte
[Applaudissements]
attention la fin les chroniqueurs alors
attention on va appeler tout de suite le
premier talent on le surnomme le
calculateur
c'est jean luc lemoine applaudissements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
isolation prise vous c'est parce qu'en
fait vous avez deux talents mais ouais
moi je suis dans ses calculs
moi je sais pas je comprend pas le
projet jean-luc je vous propose est ce
que jean luc et veut dire que 10 mois ce
qu'on voit pas bienvenu là bas mais je
sais bien c'est bien c'est pas bien
parce qu'on le voit pas alors le vois
pas de face alors jean-luc venait près
de meaux jean luc viaux p2p dire ça oui
juste content jean-luc il a un talent
exceptionnel je vous jure que c'est vrai
c'est une technologie de préciser je
voulais pas garder la surprise pour que
ce fait mais s'il est parce que j brand
dit que vous aviez un truc avant à faire
de calculs
bien sûr jean luc me souviens de
proposer des calculs mentaux calcul mon
attention
d'accord un exercice de calcul mental
pour jean-luc et vous allez voir qu'il
est excellent en moins de 5 secondes il
peut vous trouver des calculs très très
difficile vous n'êtes pas à je t'aime
beaucoup il attention 16
par 25 par 8 -
794 16 par 25 par mois
794 vous jure qu'il n'a pas d'oreillette
2406 2406 c'est la bonne réponse boire
ajouté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention deuxième quelque 243 milles
0,69
il est dur / / 79 143 milles 0,69 / 79
ans c'est impossible alors 143 milles
0,69 1811
non c'est pas possible je vous jure que
c'est 1811 sur vous jure que c'est vrai
quand même
et je pense aussi c'est pas possible
regardez non mais joli nom mais avant
après la réponse est non non non je vous
jure ici c'est moi la confiance était
mon producteur je vous jure que ça ne
peut pas truqué ses quatre derniers
calculs 12 au carré par 12 plus 1212
moins deux fois 12 - 12 par 2 12 au
carré x 12 plus 1212 moins deux fois
12.12 par deux vous dit ça va par mes
origines de 1910 c'est un truc de 1910
2009 110 ch vous jure que c'est la bonne
réponse et chez vous
et ça n'est pas truquée
chalutiers 30 alors c'est qu'il sait
danser également il sera là pour la de
leurs modèles ce deuxième talent mais
sympa et on aura bien sûr la [ __ ] aux
amusé à senna buzze et mais c'est
franchement c'est vous verrez
l'incroyable talent dès lors à dans un
instant juste avant j'aimerais qu'on
amène la reine du piano oh non j'ai des
amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas de je t'aime lara fabian
[Applaudissements]
ça fait ça fait des années que valérie
bénaïm nous dit elle sait jouer du piano
qu'elle a fait du piano pendant des
années pendant toute sa jeunesse
j'étais sûr que c'est un mytho j'ai
senti le mytho pointe et yahia ben ça
trois auteurs joly on était à la radio
j'ai dit là je la sens pas l'histoire
on l'a fait venir un piano et ben
maintenant venez là et vous n'avez genou
jouer quelque chose venait je sais hélas
non mais je me souviens que les trucs tu
connais pas par qu'un rôle elle joue
avec une partie sur ses revenus quand
mais normalement kaka qui s'est joué du
piano cela se voit tous les nains mais
ça fait des années que c'est à 6 à 16
ans
allez merci vous avez beau jour très
bien fait râler
j'étais une main en plus c'est bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel mytho minutes avant de voir
l'incroyable talent dès lors à parce que
je vous le dis celui là il est fou
lambin et non à ces six équipes n'arrive
à faire tu vas tu te sens bien depuis
d'ailleurs là on se demandera nord
devait cesser bras que je commence à
veiller à ce que vous n'allez pas être
un petit peu il avait un peu de vent
rodier sur des chaînes à ce que moi je
le connais qu'on les recommence est vrai
que j'y repense c'est bien mais c'est
pas non plus la phoniatre de haut niveau
narratif ses comptes à commencer par le
meilleur ça dommage non non non non le
meilleur ses droits c'est le meilleur
talent vous nous direz nation c'est vous
qui avez décidé que c'est mieux créer
une manne pour moi c'est au tchad mais
réalisé dans un autre rôle également à
il est également danseur car ils aiment
les chiffres mais il a aussi bouger et
oui il est tout de suite dans ce
troisième talent ça s'appelle la douleur
modène sépare
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
juste un mot
alors juste un roman duré juste voilà
génitales chez yannick heures chrono
firme est également passionnée de danse
au point d'ailleurs que j'en ai créé une
haie d'honneur models dominion petit
succès des justes dave gibbons jury vous
n y êtes
mais ce ne sont pas mes danseurs
habituel c'est de déchets je peux vous
demander quelque chose
est-ce que vous pouvez réussi comme ça
et le faire on va finir l'émission avec
bush combat oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais ça lui va beaucoup d'invitations
pour les mercis regarder et morale
incroyable talent ce sera bien et
talentueux soit avant d'accueillir 10
matchs de l'en avant d'accueillir
d'ailleurs ouais elle rentre dans une
vallée estime et mais qu'est-ce qu'on
peut juste mesure vraiment regarder et
laura qui mesure plus d'un mètre 83
mairie va rentrer dans une valise sur
vous jure c'est une petite valise un
c'est pas un énorme valise elle va
rentrer dans la valise je vais faire
mais la valise qui aurait fermé la
valise voilà je pars en vacances ça y
est j'ai tout cela j'ai touché chéri est
abîmée chaussettes c'est bon là il ya
ces chaussures aussi je vais faire mais
les servir arrête là parce que ça va et
ne reste que ça va si ça ne va pas crier
sur les noix et nora témoins compris non
masqué est là on a répété ses buts en
arrêtant enlever tous d'ailleurs
elle enlève le blouson et nora va
rentrer dans une valise et une oratrice
qui pouvait bien sûr enora et nora va
partir dans un resto pour madrid mais
pas trop longtemps
attention attention session elle quand
même regarder et nora ces bons saute
dessus et doha simon entendez dit je
vous entends je vous attends fermor même
si les incas pas de fermer une valise ah
si quand même non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
selon les sénateurs
ltd
[Applaudissements]
non
merci à genève a essayé lui aussi c'est
de faire mal je vous le problème c'est
que la vanille se rentre au bout
ne pas refaire chez vous ça
[Musique]